as China reels from the impact of the
virus some of the worst predictions
suggests that economic growth could slow
by as much as four percentage points in
this first quarter transport connections
have been brought to a standstill theme
parks and cinemas are closed with hotels
restaurants and stores all taking big
losses for neighboring Hong Kong already
in recession after months of
anti-government protests the virus has
delivered what might be described as the
perfect economic storm the gloom has
been reflected in stock markets
reopening after the Lunar New Year break
in South Korea ministers held an
emergency meeting to discuss not only
the health implications of the virus but
its impact on the economic health of the
country the government will make all-out
efforts to safeguard citizen safety and
minimize impact on the economy as long
as this new infection poses a threat
comparisons have been made with the SARS
virus in 2003 that had far-reaching
economic impact beyond China the
difference between then and now is the
size of the Chinese economy and its
relationship with the global economy
more trade more travel China is so much
more interconnected with the rest of the
world that 17 years on damage to its
economy is so much more consequential
and today the world economy is more
vulnerable facing a global downturn as
it did in 2003 generally global economy
was was very bad and and that has
affected Korea that has affected also of
China now the situation is a little
similar in the sense that you know low
global economies tend to come down after
a boom in 2017 2018
what's different it seems is the way
China has learned from past epidemics
scientifically institutionally I think
China is more prepared to control the
kind of epidemic China's success or
otherwise will have far-reaching
economic consequences for all its
neighbors Rob McBride al Jazeera Seoul
all right now we can speak to Patrick
parrot green and the international
economists at add macro joining us live
from London thank you for talking to us
I've seen a figure of 40 billion dollars
as being the cost the estimated cost of
the SARS outbreak in 2002 2003 is
probably way too early to assess what
kind of economic impact the coronavirus
this coronavirus is likely to have no I
mean it's it's very hard to quantify but
let's bear in mind when we're talking
about how much china is bigger if you
put it into hard numbers in 2003 china
was a one and a half trillion dollar
economy in terms of gdp at the end of
last year it was a for nearly a fourteen
and a half trillion dollar economy
oh it's ten times the size as a share of
global GDP it was around about four
percent now at sixteen percent it's
become an integral market for so many
companies for example Mercedes self 30
percent of their cars their BMW is
almost the same the likes of Starbucks
have over 4,000 stores and when you have
cities closing businesses for an extra
week Shanghai
Hangzhou j-jane Province these are the
large prosperous areas the most dynamic
areas with the highest income the most
productivity and well some of that
business will come back a lot of it
won't and then so I think it's when
people are talking about four percent of
GDP this quarter actually it's hard to
say well actually this quarter that's
not an annualized basis that's perfectly
realistic I think in terms of you know
before this happened people were talking
about a GDP for China this year growth
of the order of five point seven five
point eight percent right that number is
gone all right so I mean we're we're
obviously of the Chinese economy and
perhaps out of Southeast Asia is gonna
take a hit the four percent drop has
been mentioned but given that the
Chinese economy is far more integrated
into the global economy now there is a
greater a greater potential there
for contagion so the global economy is
going to feel it as well absolutely in
many countries in Asia or have very high
dependence on tourism for example
Chinese tourism to Thailand is about you
know if they're 28 percent a tourist so
tourism is about 12% of Thais GDP so
we're going to see that plummet
Australia because of its commodity
exports has a very very high exposure to
China and then even on the European side
as I mentioned before the likes of BMW
Mercedes and and also that we've seen
the luxury goods the LVMH is of this
world suffer because China again is such
a large area of sales for them so it's
the general repercussions and we look at
the European economy which is barely
struggling along growing at less than 1%
the US economy has started slow and so
this is a big difference of 2003 when we
saw a global economy was January in an
uptrend anyway so it was largely able to
brush over the sauce so I think trying
to quantify how much global GDP could
suffer by I personal rest notes it could
shave global GDP growth by at least half
a percent but when you're talking about
very low global GDP the World Bank is
talking anybody into 2 and a half
percent growth for many countries are
full to that rate is and is an effective
recession and I expect to see central
banks come out and cut interest rates
further those who have any room left to
do so and equity markets and quality
markets remain under pressure all right
Patrick parent green thank you very much
indeed for talking to us